[Music]
back again so last time I tried tiny
cooking and I feel like I was pretty
good of it looks like I'm gonna tiny
bake a cake bake a tiny cake honey bake
a tiny cake I love baking but I've never
done tiny one so there's no instructions
at all I'm just supposed to make a cake
oh boy
first thing let's grease the pan and I'm
just gonna use my fingers because I
don't see I don't see a nice brush so
I'm just gonna grease the pan I'm gonna
pour the cake mix in here who knows how
much cake mix that is I'm gonna say it's
2/3 stuff to 1/3 water we're gonna start
with that it's in next okay that is way
too much I already know this is gonna be
an eggy cake I think you should be like
folding like wait like making a rebound
okay I'm gonna pour this into it we're
gonna put the cake in I'm gonna cover
the cake we're gonna light the
briquettes so I'm gonna oh jeez that's
smokin smells like sugar is burning
let's go in it's definitely rising
maybe I overfilled it cuz it's like
almost at the top of the pan is this
left side you can see is already getting
a little burned so I'm gonna try to put
it in this corner away from that heat oh
no I don't really know how to salvage
this
I wanted to make chocolate cake and I
wanted to make ganache so I just brought
heavy cream with me I don't know if I
can make a design a tiny design with the
strawberry trying to say look at that
yeah this is what you want then I should
be shiny I should have made the cake
taller
what okay we lost a little so maybe
loose put a little bit of frosting here
sort of to act as a cake glue maybe I
can try to fill in this little hole we
have here it actually looks pretty okay
not the worst it goes oh my gosh so cute
my tiny strawberry shortcake but my
hands always shakes
[Music]
it actually tastes great tastes like
cake I think the pink save the cake mmm
you should eat it Wow yeah I think I did
pretty good at tiny baking I get the
appeal although I don't know how people
make these videos on the round nailed it
again
[Music]